[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité et
grâce à nos experts et justement cet
après-midi c'est au Sénat que
l'actualité politique se concentre avec
l'examen de la réforme des retraites
après l'Assemblée nationale c'est deux
chambres deux ambiances pas question
d'une obstruction au chaotique mais
l'opposition de gauche veut tout de même
se faire entendre nous espérons
sincèrement que le président du Sénat ne
déploiera pas certains artifices et qui
sont prévus dans le règlement du Sénat
qui permettrait de nous finalement
accélérer et de nous couper la parole en
quelque sorte dans notre premier débat
on va plonger dans ces premières heures
de travail parlementaires à la Chambre
haute et voir quel rôle le président
Gérard Larcher peut jouer pour permettre
de voter ou non le texte d'ici au 12
mars et puis juste après on va se
concentrer sur les articles modifiables
les amendements acceptables à la fois
par les LR et le gouvernement retraite
des femmes régimes spéciaux maintien de
l'équilibre budgétaire rien n'est encore
écrit vous verrez mais d'abord cette
première journée de démonstration d'une
démocratie parlementaire à l'oeuvre on
commence par cet appel lancé par le
ministre du Budget Gabriel Attal je
souhaite lancer un appel loin des
polémiques les polémiques j'adresse un
appel engageons-nous dans ce débat sans
faux-semblant et sans posture politique
un appel au compromis entre la majorité
sénatorial qui incarne la volonté d'une
réforme et la majorité présidentielle
qui porte la responsabilité de la
réforme un appel à la cohérence la
majorité sénatoriale a tant voulu cette
réforme et la voté de nombreuses fois un
appel à la responsabilité augmenter les
impôts pour financer les retraites ce
n'est pas la bonne solution car à la fin
il y en a toujours un qui paye et
celui-ci s'appelle le contribuable
j'adresse donc cet appel au Sénat
discutons amendons des bâtons mais à la
fin votons ce texte votons-le car
garantir aux Français que leur retraite
seront payées ni de droite ni du centre
ni de gauche c'est tout simplement
œuvré pour l'intérêt général voilà on va
explorer commenter analyser ces
premières heures de débat ici au Sénat
grâce à Martial Foucault bonsoir
bienvenue directeur du Sevi pof Frédéric
Daby bonsoir et bienvenue le soir
générale opinion de l'Ifop Florent
vaillaume bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
président de l'éthérique est un cercle
de réflexion qui a pour objet de
produire et diffuser une réflexion de
gauche sur l'ensemble des sujets qui
structurent la vie politique française
et puis vous êtes également enseignant à
Sciences Po et Matthieu croissanto
bonsoir Mathieu ou de vous retrouver
éditorialiste politique on reste très
ancré voilà dans ces premières heures de
débat pour commencer martial Foucault
quelles leçon vous vous tirez ce qu'on a
vu revivre le débat démocratique
c'est le souhait d'un certain nombre de
d'acteurs de cette longue séquence
autour de du projet de réforme des
retraites c'était intéressant d'entendre
Gabriel Attal parce que finalement pour
la première fois depuis très longtemps
il faudrait faire appel aux historiens
mais le Sénat a une place particulière
dans cette séquence et je crois que ce
n'est pas pour faire des plaisirs à un
certain nombre de sénateurs dont il faut
rappeler qui seront bientôt en campagne
pour leur réélection dans quelques mois
donc ce qui va se jouer devant nous
cette scène sénatoriale au Palais du
Luxembourg est intéressant à plus d'un
titre moi je vois deux enjeux importants
le premier on a dit depuis le mois de
juin 2022 que la vie politique française
allait se reparlementariser exactement
et que on allait découvrir que dans
cette fabrique de la loi les opinions
diverses allaient pouvoir être entendues
et que cela produirait des compromis
sans jamais aller sur le terrain des
compromissions bon on voit que après le
passage Assemblée nationale
ça s'est pas passé tout à fait comme
certains l'espérée donc le Sénat a une
fenêtre de tir extrêmement
importante qui doit lui permettre à
cette chambre haute d'être peut-être
plus démocratique dans les prises de
parole et aussi parce que ça a été
évoqué le temps qui peut paraître très
court 12 jours enfin 14 jours
précisément c'est peu contenu de
l'importance de ce Dex donc il y a un
enjeu est-ce que les sénateurs peuvent
faire le premier enjeu peuvent mieux
faire que les que les députés et puis un
deuxième enjeu qui est que la scène des
groupes parlementaires est totalement
différente il n'y a pas de nupes il n'y
a pas de rassemblement national
au Sénat en tout cas dans la composante
telle qu'on l'a connu à l'Assemblée
nationale donc aujourd'hui est-ce que
les sénateurs dans leur diversité de
centre droit et droites sont en mesure
de se positionner plus rapidement
demander plus facilement
ce texte et au fond revenir à leur
demande qu'il ne cessent de d'exprimer
depuis plusieurs années concernant
l'allongement de la durée au travail et
aussi la cohérence d'en parler Gabriel
Attal oui mais aussi un enjeu qui va
être celui des finances publiques et là
il y a il y a probablement pour le
gouvernement un talon d'Achille dans la
capacité à convaincre les sénateurs de
droite d'aller dans le sens de la
réforme autre citation de Gabriel Attal
dans cette même partie de discours dit
je sais qu'il n'y a ici pas de ZAD mais
la République Frédéric Daby on voit bien
à quoi il fait et référence évidemment
c'était au débat à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que dans l'opinion les Français
ont été déçus de ces débats à
l'Assemblée et qu'est-ce qu'ils
attendent du Sénat alors c'est vrai que
la scène parlementaire n'est pas une
scène très visible par les Français mais
quand même des questions d'actualité
sont vus et ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale approfondément
choquée et a été en décalage avec
l'imaginaire des Français sur une grande
réforme ils attendent un débat apaisé et
ils attendaient que le débat se focalise
sur le point qu'ils avaient le plus
retenu soit très réforme à savoir et
c'est comme ça le passage de 62 à 64 ans
comme en 2010 par homothétie tout
c'était focalisé sur le débat passons de
60 à 62 ans ou il faut le rappeler une
petite majorité de Français juger
l'effort raisonnable c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé les acteurs qui ont pour
reprendre votre terme Thomas azizer
l'Assemblée le paye dans toutes les
enquêtes de popularité Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui n'est pas député comme
vous le savez mais paye le prix de du
retour du bruit de la fureur du tumulte
et du fracas il a entraîné si je peux
dire toute la nuit peste dans son
sillage parce que il y a une équation
dans l'opinion publique qui est nupes et
galeries les filles égales Mélenchon
malgré la présence de communistes de
socialistes et des écologistes et c'est
vrai que quand on lit la phrase que vous
venez de dire de Gabriel Attal quand on
voit la stratégie que joueront beaucoup
de sénateurs ça va être une logique de
distinction par rapport à l'Assemblée
nationale pour nous alors peut-être pas
la République mais nous savons débattre
il y aura un débat apaisé pas d'effet de
manche pas de rappel de règlement
systématique peut-être un peu moins
d'amendement j'ai envie de dire même
probablement un peu moins
d'abandonnements déjà c'est 474
et c'est vrai que tout ça intervient
dans un contact dans un dans un contexte
pardon où il y a une sorte de
rééquilibrage de l'image entre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
n'oublions pas il y a pas si longtemps
que ça des débats sur une chambre
inutile le Sénat certains sondages
ont-ils supprimés le Sénat un Premier
ministre qui en avait parlé je parle de
les jossements donc voilà là c'est
peut-être un momentum propice pour le
Sénat de montrer son rôle et ça passe
avec en plus parce que quand on parle
d'une institution faut pas il faut
penser incarnation gère à l'archet
existe des Français
on en parlera évidemment on va consacrer
un chapitre de ce débat à Gérard Larcher
Florent vadillot et est-ce que si on
regarde l'équipe de nos institutions
l'assemblée à la prééminence mais on a
eu l'impression qu'elle s'était
volontairement enfin j'ai pas
volontairement mais auto effacé sur
cette réforme des recettes qui étaient
un vrai paradoxe comment vous l'avez
analysé il y a une stratégie politique
qui a conduit effectivement à
l'effacement du parlementarisme au
profit d'une mise en scène des
parlementaires c'était pas la même chose
les parlementaires étaient très présents
le parlementarisme beaucoup moins c'est
une stratégie qui était conduite
uniquement par la France insoumise qui
poursuivait un objectif assez clair qui
dit de ne pas aller voter un article et
de ce point de vue là les autres groupes
ont été vraiment en délicatesse qui
explique aussi un certain retrait et on
a vu finalement les députés n'arriver
les députés autre que les filles
arrivaient dans le combat que très
tardivement et Jérôme Guedj a été de ce
point de vue là assez éminent puisqu'il
a fait il a mis en oeuvre ses capacités
de contrôle sur pied c'est sur place à
la sécurité sociale on s'en souvient le
vent le lièvre qui aujourd'hui est un
caillou dans la chaussure du
gouvernement
on avec avec les 40000 personnes qui
aujourd'hui passent entre 10 et 20 000
personnes donc l'assemblée c'est
volontairement en tout cas sous le coup
de la frange et les filles effacé
néanmoins je pense qu'il faut raisons
garder parce que il y a déjà eu des
débats extrêmement violents à
l'Assemblée le mariage pour tous par
exemple n'était pas beaucoup plus calme
que la réforme des retraites la
différence la vraie différence c'est que
le groupe et les filles à théorisé la
lutte de classe la lutte de front en
quelque sorte à l'Assemblée la
conflictualité la conflictualité et il y
avait on pourrait être un peu dur en
disant ça suintait la haine dans les
dans les dans les prises de parole de la
France insoumise c'est ça qui est
extrêmement particulier et qui a fait
que l'assemblée était si en retrait et
finalement le Sénat est en train de
montrer que il y a une culture
sénatoriale du débat il y a une
temporalité sénatorielle du débat aussi
et le gouvernement joue là-dessus parce
que quand on regarde le taux de texte
déposé en première lecture au Sénat sous
la Cinquième République en général il
est 30% depuis la rentrée on est au-delà
de 40% certes le Sénat est clairement
privilégié par le gouvernement parce que
c'est là qu'on va pouvoir faire de la
politique et on le voit dans cette mise
en scène la politique elle est à
l'oeuvre avec les négociations mise en
scène Mathieu je vais juste rebondir sur
ce que j'ai Frédéric sur la visibilité
de la vie parlementaire il y a quand
même quelque chose qui a changé et c'est
les réseaux sociaux bien sûr de manière
qui offre une fenêtre ouverte sur cette
assemblée que les gens connaissaient mal
et sur ce qui peut s'y passer par
rapport à ce qu'on a pu ce qu'on pouvait
connaître il y a quelques années qu'on
se les questions parlementaires la
question gouvernement était diffusée sur
les six chaines sur France 3 le mercredi
après-midi quoi c'est 13 c'est quand
même très très différent et puis c'est
vrai qu'il y a la France insoumise de
par sa son idéologie à chercher à tout
conflictualiser ça c'est le théorème
Mélenchon donc on conflictualise tout à
l'Assemblée et puis à tous médiatisé
d'une certaine façon donc chacun était
un peu la recherche du buzz des députés
qui ont à peine sont élus par les
citoyens ont cherché qui sont des
députés nouveaux pour beaucoup d'entre
eux ont cherché aussi à exister par
rapport à leur circonscription existent
idéalement dans le buzz 12 parfois
certains dérapages certaines insultes
tout ça n'existe pas au Sénat où on
rappelle que les sénateurs sont élus par
des élus donc il y a pas quand même
besoin de faire des numéros de
plaquettes comme ça l'Assemblée pour
exister par ailleurs l'ambiance de
travail est différente il y a un travail
quand même d'orfèvre de la loi plus
réputé au Sénat cadassemblée c'est un
peu plus idéologique plus politique au
Sénat c'est quand même plus législatif
j'allais dire c'est vraiment des gens
qui sont des des qui font du travail
d'orfèvre sur la loi et puis les
rapports humains sont très différents
c'est-à-dire que d'un bord à l'autre
vous pouvez avoir des gens comme Bruno
Retailleau qui a beaucoup de respect
pour donc pas trop le groupe LR pour la
sénatrice communiste Elian assassy c'est
c'est des gens qui politiquement n'ont
rien à voir mais c'est tout à fait
correct on a organisé hier en seconde
partie d'émission à un débat entre
justement il y avait président de groupe
au Sénat on le ressentait c'est-à-dire
qu'ils étaient pas d'accord entre eux
c'était un vrai débat avec des
oppositions tranchées mais bon
ils se connaissent ce qui est pas le cas
à la sortie
effectivement alors on va
m'attendais à une autre
une surenchère mais c'était très bien je
vais proposer à mathiasaray de nous
rejoindre tout de suite parce que vous
avez passé l'après-midi dans l'hémicycle
alors racontez-moi un peu c'était quel
climat quelle ambiance bien sans
surprise les débats ont été plus apaisés
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale pour autant
on a vu renaître au Sénat peut-être avec
plus de force que d'habitude le clivage
gauche droite sur cette question des
retraites le gouvernement qui voulait
souligner à quel point ici au Palais du
Luxembourg l'ambiance allait être
propice au travail et bien finalement
souffler sur les braises à l'image de
cette déclaration du ministre des contes
publics Gabriel Attal en tout début de
discussion générale je sais qu'ici il
n'y a pas de ZAD il n'y a que la
République
et donc je serai tenté d'espérer
qu'après le vacarme et l'obstruction des
extrêmes s'ouvre à cet instant le temps
de la sagesse et de la raison
car je souhaite poser une question et
une seule
des senteurs de débats à l'Assemblée en
commission et dans l'hémicycle soit
davantage de temps que pour les réformes
précédentes qu'en est-il sorti de bon
pour les Français du point de vue de
ceux-là même qui s'arrogeait le monopole
de leur défense et qui ont tout fait
pour retarder les débats au fond chacun
apportera la réponse qu'il souhaite même
si je crois que les Français se sont
malheureusement fait leur avis et ne
nous ont pas attendu pour cela quel
accueille à la droite sénatoriale
a-t-elle réservée à cette réforme on a
senti du plaisir du soulagement même de
voir s'ouvrir les débats sur les bandes
de la droite et du centre des groupes
politiques qui n'ont pas boudé leur
plaisir à l'heure de rappeler que cette
réforme c'est avant tout la leur
alors pourquoi pourquoi le gouvernement
n'a-t-il donc pas jugé bon de se rallier
dès 2018 au recommandations du Sénat la
pente serait moins raide le déficit
moins abyssal que
perdu que de temps perdu néanmoins
néanmoins les faits sont là
messieurs les ministres il n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire
et la gauche comment ça s'est passé mais
elle a tenté d'exister tant bien que mal
réagissant par-ci à une missive en
prenant par trois fois officiellement la
parole pour se poser à cette réforme à
travers un rappel au règlement et deux
motions de procédures une stratégie
assumée d'opposition calme mais avec
laquelle il ne faudrait pas trop jouer
qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale on
est au Sénat on va repartir sur des
bases saines et je pense que il faut
arrêter et si vous souhaitez que que le
débat se passe bien je pense qu'il faut
arrêter avec ces provocations voilà je
pense que ça c'est des choses qu'il
fallait peut-être peut-être appeler une
première journée sans vague en somme que
le sénateur communiste Fabien gay a
plutôt bien résumé en s'adressant au
gouvernement bienvenue au Sénat et place
au débat merci
Mathias Florent Vaillot à quel point le
Sénat si on rentre un peu dans le dans
le contenu
va réécrire le texte ou au contraire
s'appuyer sur ce qui a déjà été amendé à
l'Assemblée nationale je pense que la
volonté de réécriture est importante il
y a néanmoins une limite c'est que le
texte doit être acceptable pour
l'Assemblée nationale et donc il ne peut
pas être totalement sénatoriale il faut
absolument qu'il y ait une limite de ce
point de vue là néanmoins c'est une
limite qui est uniquement vis-à-vis de
la seconde chambre parce que le
gouvernement il est piedé point lié face
au sénateur cette fois-ci et on le voit
d'ailleurs dans les amendements qui ont
été annoncés par François Patriat les
avancées sociales sont finalement très
faibles presque anecdotique l'essentiel
étant réservé au groupe de droite et
donc le gouvernement va essayer de
donner une entière satisfaction aux
républicains pour faire un appel du pied
assez fort au républicains de
l'Assemblée nationale qui on le sait ont
été parcourus de quatre consciences donc
il faut que le texte soit en quelque
sorte très sénatorial dans sa dans sa
teneur dans les avancées dans la
capacité de montrer qui des acquis
sociaux ont été pris notamment sur les
segments électoraux des républicains
mais qu'ils ne soient pas totalement
dissonant avec ce que les républicains
de l'Assemblée nationale s'attendent à
voir et par ailleurs la majorité
Renaissance fréque d'habits ici est-ce
qu'il y a si on prend un peu plus de de
recul si on sort de ces tous premiers
débats toute première heure au Sénat
est-ce qu'il y a un vainqueur dans la
bataille de l'opinion est-ce que les
syndicats est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'ils
sont un peu vainqueurs dans la bataille
de l'opinion oui on peut le dire c'était
puissance en cas de l'Ifop dont on
enquête
Ifop JDD on a vu un des syndicats qui
l'ont entend été affaiblis qui payent le
fait qu'ils n'ont pas réussi à faire
reculer la gouvernement depuis longtemps
depuis le contrat premier embauche avril
mai 2006 on voit on a vu des syndicats
qui étaient touchés par la crise de
confiance touchant un décor
intermédiaire retrouvez de la vigueur
une enquête récente donner une cote de
bonne opinion au globale de 41%. alors
c'est bien sûr minoritaire mais c'est
infiniment curieux une vingtaine de
points de plus que les parties
politiques on a vu une double
un double mouvement la CFDT bénéficiant
d'une bonne image de presque une
majorité de Français devant et faux et
la CGT quand en termes d'incarnation
Philippe Martinez malgré un mandaté
malgré une personnalité qui pouvait
susciter
des tensions être visible avec Laurent
Berger mais c'est vrai que quand on a et
la question est assez intéressante parce
qu'elle n'est pas très elle n'était pas
très orthodoxe quand on a quand on a
demandé quand on a confronté qu'il a
emporté entre la scène politique et la
scène syndicale les Français sont restés
dans l'imaginaire classique d'amour
social ou l'acteur principal c'est le
Bernard Thibault de 1995 c'est le front
syndical uni de 2010 et il s'y tête
d'abord les organisations syndicales
devant le rassemblement national qui
symboliquement malgré une une faible
visibilité et comment dire une stratégie
mais à votre chien devancer la lupesse
et la France insoumise on sait martial
Foucault qui a une j'allais dire
détestation on en est pas loin entre
entre
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Philippe Martinez
est-ce qu'il y a des relais ici au Sénat
entre le monde syndical et et les
sénateurs le monde politique est-ce que
finalement parce que là on est aussi
dans une stratégie rue
Parlement rue Sénat dans les prochains
jours c'est à ça qu'on va assister donc
est-ce qu'il y a des quels sont les
relais à votre connaissance oui le
premier relais c'est le président du
Sénat Gérard Larcher qui a
rappelons-nous la loi à l'archer sur le
dialogue social qui a contribué aussi à
établir un réseau avec les organisations
syndicales alors je dis pas qu'il est
partagé avec tous les sénateurs mais il
y a quand même une culture avec les
organisations syndicales et même
peut-être même et aussi organisation
patronale qui me semble beaucoup plus
établi au Sénat qui Assemblée nationale
ça c'est le premier élément ensuite il y
a un autre un autre sujet qui me semble
intéressant au regard de ce que ce que
disait à l'instant Frédéric Daby
au fond il y a un rendez-vous le 7 mars
le 7 mars Journée nationale on a pu
observer que l'Assemblée nationale les
deux journées de mobilisation n'ont pas
véritablement modifié la tonalité des
débats à l'Assemblée nationale on peut
on pourrait penser qu'il en sera de même
au Sénat en revanche on arrivera à une
date très particulière qui est dans
cette séquence de 14 jours c'est une
forme de saucissonnage du débat parce
que il y a un certain nombre et ça a été
tout à l'heure le témoignage sénatrice
de gauche indiquant ne nous coupez pas
la parole laissez-nous débattre mais en
fait le laisser nous débattre veut dire
essayons de retarder le plus possible
avant d'arriver à ce fameux article 7
sur les 60 de 64 ans parce que ensuite
on aura une l'accélération du temps et
pour les oppositions au Sénat c'est une
manière de dire à la fin si le temps est
raccourci on n'a pas pu débattre
inversement pour laisser la terre de
droite c'est précisément
l'idée que on ne doit pas se concentrer
sur un seul article c'est vraiment
faisons du Sénat la chambre qui est
aujourd'hui en mesure de parlementariser
la vie politique il y a un enjeu entre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat sur un
texte qui n'est pas un projet de loi qui
est un texte comme on l'a rappelé
rectificatif d'un projet de loi de
finance sécurité sociale et mais
finalement on politise à merveille le
débat et vous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure que c'est un retour du clivage
gauche-droite c'est intéressant parce
que oui on l'a pas vu à l'Assemblée
nationale la composition des groupes
parlementaires au Sénat permet
effectivement de rétablir un clivage
gauche droite sur un projet où on sait
que sur les retraites il y a une vision
de gauche et il y a une vision de droite
donc une certaine manière pour le
président du Sénat c'est c'est à dire un
coup avec deux avantages on rétablit le
clivage gauche-droite et on montre
qu'elle est parlementaires les sénateurs
peuvent débattre démocratiquement et
donc il y a effectivement il a évoqué
cette bataille de l'opinion on va dire à
gagner entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale puisqu'on parle d'image et de
communication Mathieu vous analysez la
comme gouvernementale qui entoure cette
réforme des retraites oui enfin c'est le
dernier jour parce que je la trouve en
fait un peu difficile à comprendre et
surtout qu'elle est traversée en fait
par une une vraie paradoxe qui mêle à la
fois à mes yeux un excès d'optimisme et
un excès d'alarmisme je l'explique
l'optimisme c'est le gouvernement il est
optimiste sur l'examen de sa réforme par
le scénario il faut dire qu'il a plutôt
de bonnes raisons de l'être parce qu'on
l'a dit l'ambiance y est plus sereine la
majorité est plus claire que l'assemblée
donc sur le papier voilà c'est c'est
mieux la droite qui siège en majesté en
plus au Sénat à d'ores et déjà annoncé
sa volonté de soutenir le texte ce qui
explique qu'on a assisté depuis le début
de la semaine en fait à des génération
d'intention de bonnes intentions
j'allais dire et plutôt confiante à
l'égard du Sénat de la part du chef de
l'État samedi en mars justement
l'agriculture de la part de la première
ministre en début de semaine de la part
de d'autres membres du gouvernement au
point et celle où je me dis peut-être de
pêcher par Excel optimiste parce que
pourquoi la réforme des retraites ne
passera pas comme une lettre à la poste
non plus au Sénat la droite a prévu
d'amander le texte on le sait en posant
des marqueurs claires sur des sujets qui
peuvent être consensuels comme la
retraite des femmes comme j'allais dire
plus l'emploi des seniors mais aussi sur
des questions beaucoup plus épineuses
comme on le sait les régies de spéciaux
ou aussi comme les carrières longues
alors sur les régimes spéciaux le
gouvernement après avoir fait un petit
pas de deux à déjà manifesté sur
l'opposition quand on croit carrière
longue bah la vérité obligé de dire
qu'on ne s'y retrouve plus vraiment dans
ce que veut le gouvernement puisque là
aussi Elisabeth borne a beaucoup changé
et que tout changement enfin le moindre
changement peut coûter cher voire très
cher au finances publiques donc là ça
aussi ça risque de tirer on a entendu
tout à l'heure Gabriel Attal dire
attention pas d'augmentation d'impôts
donc on sait qu'il tient lui à ce le
feuille de route qui est fixé madame
Macron c'est à dire l'équilibre du
régime et puis du côté de la gauche la
gauche c'est la tour de gauche ont
répété qui feraient pas d'obstruction
comme leurs collègues dépités ils ont
annoncé leur souhait d'examiner le
projet de loi au moins jusqu'à l'article
7 et je dis au moins parce qu'ensuite il
y a un flou est-ce qu'ils iront jusqu'au
bout du texte on ne le sait pas ils sont
pas prononcés très très clairement et ce
qu'ils iront donc jusqu'au vote pas non
plus donc de quoi tempérer un peu
l'optimisme du Gouvernement sur ce coup
ça c'est pour l'excès d'optimisme alors
pour la larmisme cette alarme s'il est
face à la rue le gouvernement donne dans
l'excès de pessimisme il y avait qu'à
écouter hier les déclarations je sais
pas si vous avez entendu d'Olivier Véran
à la sortie du Conseil des ministres sur
il s'exprimer sur la journée du 7 mars
c'est sur la volonté des syndicats de
mettre la France à l'arrêt et il a tout
simplement promis évidemment
l'Apocalypse aux français puisque ça
serait la fouine catastrophe écologique
agricole sanitaire voire humaine dans
quelques mois menaçant au passage et
pour faire l'argent aussi bien de en
train du futur du plan ferroviaire que
la santé des enfants avec le vaccin pour
le papillomavirus un énorme gloubiboulga
de n'importe quoi il faut le dire alors
on voit bien l'idée derrière la tête
d'Olivier Vérand un dramatisé à mort
pour faire peur à tout le monde mais
cette grosse ficelle est aussi un aveu
de faiblesse à mes yeux parce que elle
montre que le gouvernement redoute le
mouvement plutôt qu'il ne l'écoute ça on
le savait elle montre aussi que le
gouvernement n'a plus rien à offrir
j'allais dire en termes de défense en
terme d'argumentaire quelque chose qui
qui passe dans l'opinion et c'est pas
une surprise mais la confirmation que
deux mois on est deux mois après la
présentation du du projet de loi et
belle exécutif a définitivement perdu la
bataille de l'opinion qui juge cette
réforme enfin fabrique nous dira mais
toujours aussi injuste inutile et puis
inefficace donc c'est quand même assez
hallucinant je trouve le gouvernement
était sourd sans le savait il est devenu
inaudible vis-à-vis du mouvement et il
est surtout dépourvu aujourd'hui
d'arguments alors quand vous n'avez plus
cheval de bataille et ben vous sortez
les épouvantails et c'est exactement ce
qu'a fait Olivier verin justement
Frédéric Davy ce on l'a bien compris
c'est dramatisation à l'extrême de
d'Olivier Véran est-ce que ça peut quand
même payer dans une partie de l'opinion
c'est français qui
refusent ou ont peur d'une d'un pays
bloqué ça peut marcher il y a un
précédent le mouvement des gilets jaunes
qui est soutenu massivement par les
Français au fur et à mesure des
violences le gouvernement
agitent le registre de la chanlie du
désordre qu'est-ce qu'on voit alors que
ce segment était très mécontent les
personnes âgées des retraités elles
venaient d'enregistrer la hausse de la
CSG à leur rencontre craindre du une
chenille du désordre et fait un peu
effet un peu on serre les rangs avait
contribué à une remontée de la
popularité assez spectaculaire du
domaine Macron tout gouvernant et qui a
débouché sur la semi-victoire ou la
semi-dessêtes ou la défaite honorable
aux élections européennes de 2019
maintenant ça supposerait par nos
imprompre effectivement on sait qu'il y
a des préavis de grève reconductible etc
mais ce que ça soit cette mars et
plusieurs autres et il faut être honnête
personne ne sait ce qui peut se passer
ce qu'on va avoir un scénario à la 95 et
surtout il y a pas de débordement parce
que tout ce que les Français ont aimé
c'est ce que j'avais appelé des
manifestations retour vers le futur
c'est à dire calme bon enfant son album
en rupture avec ce qui avait commencé en
2015-2016 au moment de la loi travail du
1er mai 2016 ou un McDonald's avait été
brouillé etc ça ça avait beaucoup plus
bas c'est vrai que la journée le
désordre on verra ce qui se passera pour
l'instant il n'existait pas nous ce ne
sont que des hypothèses un dernier point
quand même peut-être le seul atout pour
le gouvernement dans cette bataille de
l'opinion est-ce qu'elle dit Mathieu est
tout à fait juste absolument perdu c'est
le fait que malgré tout et on a posé
cette question à cinq reprises depuis la
première journée les Français
intériorissent toujours que Emmanuel
Macron ne pourra pas ne pas reculer que
la loi sera votée ou appliquée sur un on
est sur un deux tiers
encore une fois mais que en perspective
de cette journée du 7 mars et peut-être
des suivantes et un peu d'espoir qui
commence à germer de bah finalement
peut-être que le gouvernement
elle est fit qui était au tout début
lors de la première journée je crois du
du 19 janvier était à une majorité du
dire non c'est un baroud d'honneur le
gouvernement ne rentrera pas maintenant
ils sont une forte majorité à croire
qu'il va reculer mais c'est la seule
famille politique qui est dans cette
logique là alors je voudrais qu'on
continue de d'évoquer la la construction
de de cette loi ce qu'on attend
peut-être des prochains jours ici au
Sénat c'est d'assister à l'écriture
quasi définitive on verra bien de la de
la réforme et alors vous l'avez un peu
évoqué il y a des stratégies qui
s'opposent forcément notamment sur cet
article 7 dont on parle qui repousse je
vous le rappelle l'âge de la retraite à
64 ans le président du groupe LR au
Sénat Bruno Retailleau mettent en garde
ses adversaires écoutez-le
prévient d'ailleurs nous oppositions ils
veulent voter par exemple article 7 très
bien ils veulent voter l'article 7 le 7
mars au moment de la mobilisation de la
grève après le 7 mars Patrick Kamel le
patron des sénateurs socialistes dit il
y a une sorte de d'accord c'est à dire
que on se dit qu'on ne votera pas
l'article 7 avant le 7 mars c'est c'est
mars et nous ne tolérerons pas ou ne
tolérant pas qu'on ne voit pas les
articles suivants article 8 9 et 10
l'article 10 les titres ça n'intéresse
pas la gauche de discuter pour les
Français des petites retraites l'article
9 l'usure professionnelle c'est pas
intéressant d'en parler d'en discuter de
voter l'article 8 l'invalidité
l'incapacité les travailleurs
je reviens vous l'avez tout à l'heure la
perspective des élections sénatoriales
en septembre il y a quand même un risque
pour les sénateurs de d'apparaître comme
le sénateur qui un peu un peu qui
pratique l'obstruction c'est à vous
pensez que ça peut être un risque
politique ça
oui parce que tout à l'heure Mathieu
croissanto parler de l'effet des réseaux
sociaux
je voudrais qu'il y a aussi un effet de
la visibilité médiatique et la Chaîne
parlementaire a contribué rares sont les
débats sur des textes qui donnent lieu à
une séquence en direct aussi longue donc
il y a eu forcément à ce débat est
rentré pour ceux qui regardent encore la
télévision et rentrer dans dans les
salons de beaucoup de Français et pour
beaucoup de Français qui sont privés de
l'élection directe des sénateurs
il y a quand même un j'allais dire un
effet qui ne faut pas sous-estimer que
l'ensemble des élus qui constituent le
corps électoral des sénateurs sont très
à l'affût de ce qui se dit et ce qui se
passe dans les communes sur le sujet des
retraites et donc beaucoup de sénateurs
vont être très vigilants sur des
positions à prendre et je crois que
Bruno retaillod a raison au-delà de
l'article 7 certains d'entre eux
certains des notamment le corps
électoral principal des des sénateurs
vont être très vigilants sur les
positions prises par un certain nombre
de de sénateurs parce qu'on le sait on
dit souvent l'élection sénatoriale et
presque apolitique ce qui compte c'est
l'élection des représentants des
territoires bon là c'est un enjeu de
société cette cette réforme puis je
rajoute un point qui moi qui me paraît
et important encore une fois je poursuis
ce que disait tout à l'heure Mathieu
croissanto
en fait on a la confirmation et je sais
pas comment les sénateurs vont
réellement
se positionner on a la confirmation que
si le gouvernement est à court
d'arguments pour convaincre l'opinion ça
confirme que ce projet a été très très
mal élaboré très très mal ficelé parce
que au fond si on épuise aussi
rapidement tous les arguments qui sont
en termes de finance publique en termes
sociales aussi en termes de vision
intergénération exceptionnel ça veut
dire qu'il a manqué probablement dans la
préparation des arguments qui pourraient
contrer cette question de l'âge 62 à 64
ans donc est-ce que les sénateurs vont
enfoncer un clou aujourd'hui parce que
c'est une bataille aussi politique la
majorité au Sénat n'a pas forcément
envie de faire des cadeaux au
gouvernement ou bien est-ce que les
sénateurs vont sauver
la réforme qui s'annonce comme la
réforme phare du président Macron donc
vous voyez on peut aller très très loin
dans le soutien mais ensuite on
reprochera au sénateur s'ils ont trop
soutenus cette réforme pour que
effectivement tout soit examiné voté
pour éviter le passage en commission mix
paritaire et bien d'avoir accompagné et
d'avoir aidé et d'avoir fait la courte
échelle expression qu'on entend si
souvent la béquille gouvernement Florent
je le rappelle 4720 amendements qui ont
été déposés alors c'est beaucoup moins
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale mais et il y
a plus de temps ici au Sénat il y a je
crois un tiers de temps en plus pour
examiner le
la réforme est-ce que si vous deviez
faire un pari tiens est-ce que vous
pensez qu'on ira au bout du texte
c'est compliqué de faire un pari comme
ça la dernière fois que j'ai fait un
pari sur votre plateau je l'ai perdu
c'est compliqué de répondre parce qu'il
y a plusieurs stratégies qui sont
ambivalentes pour la gauche d'abord il y
a un intérêt effectivement c'est d'aller
au moins jusqu'à l'article 7 parce que
ça va obliger LR et Renaissance à en
quelque sorte mettre en place une
communauté de point de vue et ce qui
permettra ensuite d'accentuer le clivage
gauche droite et de casser cet
indistinction de la part de renaissance
donc ça c'est nécessaire en revanche sur
les articles suivants il y a pas une
claire volonté d'y aller je pense que la
stratégie encore n'est pas définitive
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
effectivement ça dépendra de la
mobilisation sociale si le 7 mars c'est
une mobilisation dure peut-être que la
gauche se sentira revigorée et puis
surtout il y a un troisième tour si je
peux me permettre c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel plus le texte sera abîmé
dans son débat parlementaire plus les
débats auront été tronqués l'insincérité
des débats parlementaires plus le
Conseil constitutionnel pourra décider
une censure partielle ou intégrale il
faut rappeler que dans un off avec les
journalistes le président
plus émis une insatisfaction voire une
colère de voir que un artifice
constitutionnel était utilisé pour
examiner le projet de loi pour les
retraites donc il y a peut-être la
stratégie de la gauche désolé sur
l'inconstitutionnalité du texte et donc
ce qui expliquerait effectivement que il
y a beaucoup d'amendements qui étaient
posés puis enfin il y a un sujet pour
Renaissance également c'est que à trop
donner à trop faire de concessions aux
républicains et bien il va avoir un
problème à gérer sa propre majorité pas
tant au Sénat qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
parce que on l'a vu notamment sur les
députés qui annonçaient qu'ils ne
voteraient pas le texte le groupe était
beaucoup divisé sur ce sujet là donc
plus le gouvernement ira vers les LR au
Sénat plus l'aura de la difficulté à
souder ses troupes à l'Assemblée
nationale donc je ne peux pas me prendre
un pari à ce stade là
pour pour illustrer ce que vous disiez à
l'instant tiens je vous propose un autre
extrait de de Bruno taillot ce matin en
télévision
le prénom du groupe LR au Sénat qui
justement dit on n'est pas on n'est pas
des girouettes et notre boussole c'est
pas le président de la République on
l'écoute pour lever tout suspense je
voudrais dire que bien sûr nous allons
voter un texte qui sera notre texte
c'est à dire que nous voterons la
réforme une réforme modifiée une réforme
que nous allons amender selon les
prescriptions
qu'il a fait avec pédagogie qui avec
humour du docteur sur le rapporteur René
Paul Savary
de quoi aurions-nous l'air mes chers
collègues si nous refusions de voter une
réforme que nous votons ici chaque année
depuis plusieurs années nous ne sommes
pas des girouettes notre boussole ce
n'est pas email Macron ça n'est pas le
gouvernement c'est l'intérêt national
c'est le seul international
Bruno Retailleau au Sénat en cette fin
d'après-midi je voulais promis on va
consacrer un chapitre
dans ce débat au rôle de Gérard Larcher
alors ce matin dans Le Figaro qui a un
extrait de son interview il prévient je
suis un défenseur acharné du droit
d'amendement mais il ne faut pas le
dévoyer s'il devait y avoir une
obstruction d'utilisera tout simplement
les moyens constitutionnels et ceux de
notre règlement je ferai le maximum
qu'un président d'assemblée peut faire
pour aller au bout de ce débat
Frédéric Davis commence avec vous ce
chapitre comment parce que vous sortez
je crois dans Paris Match
un sondage voilà comment est-il perçu
par les français Gérard c'est comme un
opposant ou comme un conciliant
clairement inconscient inconscient alors
c'est une enquête ou chaque mois nous
testons les traits d'images associés à
des personnalités c'était Bruno Le Maire
il y a 2 mois Olivier Véran le mois
dernier là Gérard archer alors quand on
regarde les résultats on peut dire bah
c'est une personnalité plutôt pas bien
vu parce qu'il n'y a pas un seul trait
d'images qui dépasse les 50 % mais il
faut bien rappeler le contexte on est
plus dans une bipolarisation on a une
des opinions extrêmement éclatée quand
on regarde si je puis dire le cœur de
cible qui peut intéresser à l'archer à
savoir LR et Renaissance son image est
absolument excellente il apparaît au 3/4
comme compétent aux deux tiers voire
trois quarts chez les air comme ouvert
au dialogue et c'est marqué sur votre
écran ce qu'on voyait l'item le moins
bien perçu c'est l'opposition s'oppose
et c'est un item qui n'est pas en fait
anodin on le posait à l'époque de la de
la bipolarisation m'ont demandé est-ce
que le PS s'oppose fortement et bien
jusque là Sarkozy est-ce que l'UMP
s'opposait bien à François Hollande et
là le fait que les résultats soient pas
très bons c'est c'est ça montre aussi
cette place particulière que j'ai à
l'arraché comme quelqu'un d'ouvert au
dialogue compétent projet proche des
préoccupations j'ai envie de dire une
image en terme d'ouverture et en termes
de proximité qui s'inscrit en rupture
avec les principales critiques adressées
au pouvoir exécutif voir à une classe
politique souvent jugée déconnectée et
le fait que le résultat soit pas très
bon sur l'opposition j'ai envie de dire
radical et dur est-ce que c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour un président du
Sénat je ne pense pas je rappelle
également on réalise un moment de chaque
élection sénatoriale et un peu plus
souvent une enquête sur l'image du Sénat
du pyjamarchais et Président on a vu
systématiquement les indicateurs d'image
se renforcer et une rupture également
très forte avec l'épisode Jean-Pierre
Bella martial Foucault qu'est ce qui se
joue pour Gérard Larcher là dans les
dans les vous l'avez un peu évoqué tout
à l'heure mais peut-être même aussi pour
son rôle de président du Sénat
il y a effectivement l'élection en point
de mire en septembre prochain avec
le soutien qui doit obtenir d'une
majorité de sénateurs pour entamer
peut-être une deuxième décennie à la
tête de
la chambre haute je crois que si l'image
en fait positive dont bénéficie Gérard
Larcher aujourd'hui dans dans l'opinion
publique elle est aussi forte moi j'y
vois deux raisons et qui entre en
résonance avec le débat qu'il va qu'il
va présider
premier
élément c'est Gérard Larcher il faut
bien voir que dans sa famille politique
a fait l'objet d'une très grande
stabilité on pourrait même parler d'une
fidélité d'une loyauté en étant présent
sans prendre des positions trop
conflictuelles et ça finalement dans son
hectolera mais aussi mais aussi dans
l'électorat Renaissance c'est un trait
d'image qui plaît et puis un deuxième
élément Gérard Larcher depuis qu'il est
président du Sénat
n'a qu'un enjeu c'est celui de se
positionner comme vraiment le
représentant des territoires être
représentant des territoires c'est à
beaucoup d'avantages c'est-à-dire que on
peut se saisir de ce qui n'est pas
débattu par un gouvernement et un
président de la République qui n'a pas
fait depuis 2017 des territoires
un enjeu de son agenda de réforme donc
j'ai arraché a pu bénéficier de cette de
cet espace libéré par un président et
rappelons-nous la crise des gilets
jaunes mouvement des gilets jaunes
écrites et territoires donc une fois dit
cela pendant ces 15 prochains jours au
Sénat sur la réforme de retraite on va
peut-être découvrir un Gérard Larcher
capable de modérer des débats quand il
évoque dans l'entretien au Figaro ce
matin que tout les instruments
disponibles seront mobilisés en cas
d'obstruction je
je pense que c'est davantage une
position une posture consistant à dire
je je suis le gardien au Sénat de ce qui
doit se passer de façon pacifiée qui ne
s'est pas produit à l'Assemblée
nationale et en sur ce terrain là
effectivement il doit pouvoir compter
aussi sur l'ensemble de la majorité de
droite au Sénat et qui pourrait au mois
de septembre lui renvoyait l'ascenseur
Mathieu hameau
sur les moyens de général archer pour
que faire face à l'obstruction et comme
une particularité au Sénat dans le
règlement du Sénat c'est l'article 38
qui permet que les débats s'éternise pas
ou assemblée puisque à partir du moment
où deux orateurs la vie contraire ont
pris la parole vous pouvez demander
quand vous êtes président de groupe
présent de séance ou président du Sénat
la clôture de la discussion
c'est c'est quand même une arme atomique
j'allais dire mais qui est très très
très différente de ce qui peut se passer
à l'Assemblée et c'est ce qui est
sous-entendu d'ailleurs dans l'extrait
de l'interview du Figaro qu'on a aurait
fallu à l'instant un petit point parce
qu'on évoqué tout à l'heure Gérard lâché
le dialogue social ce n'est pas pour
rien que j'ai relâché bénéficie aussi
d'une image d'un négociateur capable de
pouvoir convaincre certains groupes
parlementaires tous les groupes
parlementaires au Sénat ne sont pas
élèves et je crois que après 10 ans à la
tête du Sénat contrairement à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
Gérard Larcher a ce capital politique
qui peut être décisif s'il y avait
effectivement un ralentissement ou une
temporalité qui n'est pas celle qui
permettrait de faire en sorte que le
Sénat l'objectif du Sénat c'est de dire
nous avons réussi à voter l'ensemble de
ce texte Florent m'a dit pour les LR on
l'a évoqué déjà dans ce débat mais on
peut dire qu'ils sont sur quand on
compare finalement le travail qui a été
fait à
l'Assemblée et celui qui commence et qui
va être fait au Sénat il y a un enjeu
c'est pas totalement détricoté et faire
en sorte que la réforme telle qu'elle
sera éventuellement
[Musique]
brouiller un peu cette ligne de crête là
et puis on le voit il a été un dissident
sanctionné puisque même Gérard Larcher
dans son interview Figaro n'a pas des
mots très aimables à son égard donc les
républicains en dehors du Sénat à mon
sens ils ont une stratégie politique qui
est extraordinairement complexe à
conduire pour conclure ce premier débat
les les sympathisants et l'air par cette
réforme qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
est-ce qui sont eux aussi un peu
partagés j'allais rebondir ce que oui
parce que le Bica mérisme républicain
joli expression dont vous parlez on le
retrouve en terme de fracture chez les
sympathisants et l'air dans toutes les
enquêtes on est sur un sympathisant et
l'air sur deux seulement qui soutient la
réforme des retraites alors que pendant
le premier quinquennat on a parlé de
Sainte Alliance LR lrem ce n'est pas
encore Renaissance sur la réforme de la
SNCF la première réforme des retraites
sous la réforme du Code du travail qui
soutenait les réformes libérales ou de
structures là cette fracture on la voit
et c'est vrai que les LR de l'Assemblée
nationale qui ont vu des des zones de
force complètement perdu au profit de la
Renaissance sont sur une opposition très
forte et le discours très intéressant de
Bruno autaio sur la cohérence nous
étions contre la retraite à 60 ans nous
étions nous avons soutenu la réforme
Sarkozy fille on verse on ne peut pas ne
pas soutenir ça dépend bien et a été
très peu présent sauf erreur à
l'Assemblée nationale merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
premier débat bientôt sur public sén